un intento de motín que terminó en
incendio unos 200 reclusos de una cárcel
de tuluá e iniciar una revuelta y se
vieron involucrados en una conflagración
provocada en el penal dejando decenas de
fallecidos pero la situación que tenemos
hasta ahora no es un misterio público no
hemos podido ingresar porque había un
hermetismo del infectó nosotros nuestra
procura es que se genere la información
necesaria para los familiares hasta
ahora el conocimiento inicial son 49
fallecidos número 30 heridos de centros
hospitalarios de la ciudad los
familiares de los prisioneros esperan a
una información de sus seres queridos
necesitamos que
me muestra allí en el patio donde
sucedió todo esto pero no sabemos
no tenemos los son algunas
las autoridades consideraron que la
tragedia fue producto de un intento de
fuga el gobierno colombiano anunció una
investigación
lamentamos los hechos ocurridos en la
cárcel de turba valle del cauca estoy en
contacto con el director del inpec
general tito castellanos y ha dado
instrucciones para adelantar
investigaciones que permitan esclarecer
esta terrible situación mi solidaridad
con las familias de las víctimas al
igual que en otros países
latinoamericanos en colombia las
cárceles están superpobladas según
cifras oficiales las exclusiones tienen
capacidad para 81 mil reclusos y para
mejorar las condiciones de hacinamiento
el gobierno entrante podría abordar este
tema el estado colombiano ha mirado la
cárcel como un espacio de venganza y no
de rehabilitación lo acontecido en tuluá
como la masacre de la modelo obliga un
replanteamiento completo de la política
carcelaria de cara a la humanización de
la cárcel y la dignificación del preso
administraciones pasadas fallaron en el
intento